afternoon to you um this is such
terrible news for so many people who
will be driven even further into poverty
what do you have to say to them
well i talk to customers all the time
and i know for many of them this is a
huge shock it's been talked about for
some time but the reality of a 54 rise
is bigger than we've seen at least in
the last 20 years but off jim's job here
is to make sure that people pay a fair
price for their energy and no more than
that and the reason this price has gone
up so much
is because the international markets the
gas markets themselves are charging a
lot more both for the gas and indeed
therefore for the electricity that we
use i am pleased that government stepped
in it's not my job to comment on whether
that's enough but i know at the end of
the day this is still a big shock for
many families and i talk to many
families so i understand the different
consequences that this will have for all
of those those people
is this correct to say that this is the
eighth time the cap has been set since
it was introduced in january 2019.
yes that's right
that is such a very worrying trajectory
i mean what are your predictions for the
future because there's there's to be um
an overall in autumn i believe what do
you suggest that that might be
well i think we need to be really
cautious about what people are saying
about the future of the gas market the
truth is the gas market is more volatile
than we've ever seen it before so to be
honest we're not seeing signs that
prices will come down quickly but
equally this is really isn't predictable
there are huge global factors here at
play now the amount of gas that a
country like china might use has a big
impact on the market and clearly some of
the geopolitical things that we are
seeing have a big impact on whether
prices will go up or down so what i say
to customers is look we have to be
honest with you we're not seeing signs
that prices will fall but things are
very hard to predict but what i can
commit to as soon as those wholesale
prices come down the price cap will come
down just as quickly as it's come up
but what assumptions are you making
about the direction of oil and gas
prices for the the rest of the year
because that that is within your your
remit but what are you
looking ahead to what are you thinking
so what we look at is what everyone
looks at which is what's called the
forward market so it's what the traders
are pricing the future at but as i say
those are changing quite dramatically
almost week by week
so we are we're not seeing signs that
prices are coming down quickly but it
really isn't right to be predicting
things that are simply too hard to
predict right now so all those people
saying what will happen to prices in the
future you know they're making their
best projections but honestly we don't
know what will happen to prices what i
would say though is that price we're not
seeing signs that prices are going to
come down and i know that's a tough
message for families and we understand
the impact that's happening across the
country
and and how worried are you i know
you're saying that you can't predict an
awful lot but how worried are you about
the prospect of russia
weaponizing that the gas supply to
europe and the knock-on effect of that
well you know i think your last
interview he said that he was following
the gas price almost hour-by-hour well
here we and ofgem are doing the same now
clearly russia is a big supplier of gas
so their activity will have an impact on
prices but what we are seeing is the
global market beginning to work and gas
coming from other sources so many more
people were worried at the start of
winter but what we've seen is what's
called lng so gas that comes in ships
really ramping up to make sure that we
have adequate security supply and manage
some of the prices we've seen but
clearly though the actions of russia
will make a difference on price just as
the demand from countries across asia
will also have an impact on price we've
seen huge changes in this market we've
seen huge volatility and unfortunately
that does need to come through to
customers bills but offgem with
government and the industry will do
everything we can to manage this on
behalf of customers particularly those
most vulnerable
i mean customers have had to take a huge
hit um and will want to know whether
they should prepare themselves for more
um with hand on heart and in all honesty
is there any other projection than
actually an increase to come more
increases to come
well as i say the projections are just
simply not reliable but we're not seeing
signs that prices are going to fall we
are seeing what is forward prices that
are higher than you'd normally expect
and that really is down to those global
factors that i've described what i say
to any customer though is if you are
struggling to pay your bills then get in
touch with your energy supplier talk to
them
we have put rules in place so they will
treat you fairly and equally they should
give you access to the sort of advice
you need to be able to manage your
finances not just in energy but across
the whole of the household bill
okay so good advice there from off gym
ceo jonathan brilly thank you very much
for speaking to me this afternoon